ladies and gentlemen there is light at
the end of the tunnel our voices our
actions
our beliefs our philosophies if we put
them into play we actually can make
change we really can we can get rid of
their woke agenda we can get rid of the
corporate ESG agenda when they see the
bottom line ain't working anymore and
here is some video from CNN it is
officially true Bud Light is no longer
America's number one beer
so this morning after two decades a new
top-selling beer in the U.S Mexican
lager Modelo Especial was the top
selling beer last month overthrowing Bud
Light there are a couple things at play
here including flat out changing taste
but also the backlash from a social
media post by transgender influencer
Dylan Mulvaney right right it was first
off before that thing before the boycott
the cost of the billions it was just
people's tastes were changing suddenly
people realized you know I don't like
drinking this lukewarm piss
oh I finally came around on it no it was
all because of the boycott obviously now
interestingly Modelo which originally
was a Mexican beer is actually owned by
the same company Anheuser-Busch inbev
which is the parent company of Bud Light
also owns Modelo now will people
eventually boycott Modelo would that be
just or anything else like I don't think
because of the decision basically of a
couple idiotic people over at Bud Light
like we should be taking out everybody I
just think that's an interesting thing a
little piece of context within the wider
world of of how Corporate America seems
to work
[Music]
thank you